and joining me now from the frontlines
in the fight against the coronavirus
assistant to the president for trade and
manufacturing Peter Navarro Peter thanks
so much for being with us tonight hey
judge thank you the the the the most
important question right now is what do
we need and how do we get to the to what
we need sure
personal protective equipment that's the
the front line for our health care
workers in order to take this virus on
and what we have Jeanine is the full
force of the federal government the full
power a private enterprise in the full
cooperation and the American people as
they practice their social distancing
and do what needs to be done to fight
the virus in their way but it's really
been gratifying to me to work here at
the White House and see how this
government is working so well with the
private sector to get things done and
I'd like to just give you a couple of
examples as some of them will hit pretty
close to home there's a company called
Pernod Ricard that makes alcoholic
beverages and got a call last week they
wanted to take some their production
line across four states like Arkansas
Kentucky and make hand sanitizers so as
we speak there's a truck moving to New
York City with their first batch that's
going to be there on Tuesday and and
delivered directly to hospitals there's
a company called ASO which I just talked
with today
and today we were able to get half a
million gloves from ASO in Palmetto
Florida to the hospitals in New York
it's going to be landing tomorrow and in
Sloan another company in Texas again
just talked to them today and we're
getting tens of thousands of full jump
suits and and booty covers that are
going to go to both Seattle and New York
City and this is over and above what
FEMA is doing from the stockpiles
the Honeywell we've been able in just a
week to get them to start staffing up a
factory in Smithfield Rhode Island to
increase their production of masks
there's a coalition the National Council
of trade organizations led by woman in
Kim glass very dynamic figure she's put
together companies that usually make us
our undergarments and t-shirts things
like that Hanes Fruit of the Loom
Parkdale Mills they're going to be
making three ply masked and we should
have that up in production as well so so
we've got planes in the air from FEMA
FedEx and then the military going all
across this great country and sometimes
bringing stuff from around the world so
that we get what we need in real time
well for the American people and this is
what the Trump administration is
bringing together in this crisis and you
know Peter what you're talking about is
it's the third point of but the open
that I just made and that is the common
ground that people who aren't for
example pernod ricard who aren't
normally in the business of making
sanitizers I mean they're in the alcohol
business and I understand that you were
an individual who was able to cut
through the what was it the both the FHA
as well as and other departments to make
it go smoother look this is a
whole-of-government approach I
understand that but let's talk about
what we're going to do in in in getting
this stuff to all the people who need it
now I know and the next guest on my show
why laughter dr. ben Carson is dr. Steve
Corwin who is the head of New York
Presbyterian they are desperate for
masks and I understand that now some are
going to to them but how do we get how
do we get to the point where this never
happens again that's a great question
and the problem we face and as I try to
solve these problems for the White House
in the president hey here's the thing
Janine our supply chains for medicines
medical supplies and medical equipment
it spread out all
over the world and that works fine when
there's no problem and you don't need
them but check this out we buy about a
hundred and twenty billion dollars of
medicines every year from the rest of
the world about ninety-five percent of
them come in from about 20 countries
guess what judge ten of those countries
have already imposed some forms of
export restrictions on things that we
actually need and it's it's a situation
where we found ourselves in many of our
sections in the economy where we've
offshored our jobs machine tools
electronics steel whatever it is that
cost us jobs in this case it costs us
lives and so one of the lessons I hope
we learned after this is over is to
bring those jobs home here to America so
that we can make the medicines make the
facemask and have what we need here you
know what for an administration Peter
you know with with President Trump
America first made in America that makes
perfect sense it's time to tell the rest
of the world that we're not going to
rely on them anymore especially when it
comes to our medications and you know
for me nuclear medicine as well as
something that makes me crazy as well
but Peter Navarro thank you for what
you're doing I just want to know how you
guys are able to do this 24/7 and you
all still look great well I am just so
proud of this president and in this
country and the people working in
government and business right now and
and the people of America who are
cooperating with what they need in terms
of social distancing so I salute you and
now let's stay on it here and let's make
sure we get this done for the American
people thank you we salute you as well
thanks for being with us tonight